Tensions are rising
in one of
the most hotly contested
regions on the planet,
the South China Sea,
from militarized
artificial islands to fighter jets
and warplanes.
China's
heavy presence in the disputed
region is putting the US
and its allies on notice.
CNN got rare access aboard a U.S.
Navy surveillance
flight
and saw firsthand
some tense moments with China's military.
Here's CNN's Ivan Watson.
This is a close encounter
with a Chinese warplane
filmed just off the wing of a U.S.
Navy reconnaissance
plane flying over the South China Sea.
We're getting a close up
look at a Chinese fighter jet.
The air crew here identifies it
as a shell.
11, a two seater that they say
is armed with air to air missiles.
And it's been shadowing this U.S.
Navy, playing now for about 15 minutes.
It is pretty remarkable
to see this Chinese warplane operating
at such close proximity
just several hundred feet away
from our aircraft.
I don't know how
the Chinese fighter
escort part of a regular routine.
I'd say it's another Friday afternoon
in the South China Sea. The U.S.
Navy invited
CNN to fly on a P-8 reconnaissance plane
taking off from a U.S.
air base on the Japanese
island of Okinawa
at 300 on September six.
Along the way,
picking up fuel
from a flying gas station.
We're refueling in midair
right now, flying just about 40 feet away
from a KC one 35 tanker plane.
The plane
is headed past
the self-governing island of Taiwan,
which China claims as its own,
to the South China Sea, which China
also claims almost all for itself,
ignoring competing
claims from countries like Vietnam
and the Philippines.
Some 30 miles from the Chinese occupied
Paracel Islands.
A Chinese voice crackles over the radio.
American aircraft
they think of the Air Force.
You are approaching Chinese,
offering a safe distance.
In fact, that's when the Chinese people's
Liberation Army fighter jet
appears flying
so close
you can see the pilots in their cockpit,
a fighter aircraft, and then
on one, two, one, four, five,
I I'll drop my left
wing and I will continue to proceed
to the west.
The Chinese pilot never responds,
but eventually leaves when the U.S.
plane turns south. And
its like oil spots as they build
as they build on one reef
and then build on another
Commodore will tourists
and shows the network of manmade islands
China built
on what had been coral reefs
claimed by other countries.
Our number one focus here
is to ensure
that we have continued access
alongside all of our allies and partners
to international airspace
and international waters.
The U.S.
presence here
aimed at preventing further encroachment
by China experts.
The captain knows
we're flying at a low altitude,
a thousand feet,
a little more than 300 meters
above sea level east of Taiwan.
Looking for a Chinese warship
currently believed to be operating
in these stormy waters.
The plane spots
a Chinese guided missile destroyer.
And we have our target very hard to call.
Mean I'll be.
I'm a
United States
military aircraft and our marionette,
a cat and mouse game
between two rival militaries
in one of the most
hotly contested regions in the world.
Ivan Watson, CNN,
over the South China Sea for.